bonjour à tous place dans un instant à
une audition organisée par la commission
des finances du Sénat consacrée aux
monnaieses virtuelles au fameux Bitcoin
alors le Bitcoin qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est à la fois et bien un système de
paiement sur internet et l'unité de
compte de ce système de paiement alors
faut-il l'autoriser l'interdire le taxer
est-ce que le Bitcoin est un danger pour
la sûreté financière les parlementaires
se posent de nombreuses questions à
propos de cette innovation et c'est
pourquoi la commission des finances a
organisé cette audition les
parlementaires doivent comprendre le
phénomène pour pouvoir organiser
contrôler ce phénomène tout de suite
donc direction la salle
clémau euh je me tourne vers monsieur
denibaau directeur génér génér des
opérations à la Banque de France de quoi
s'agit-il est-ce que ça vous soucie
quels
sont si oui vos préoccupations quels
sont vos conseils à la
représentation
nationale merci de bien vouloir vous
exprimer sans
détour merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président bonjour bonjour monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs euh je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier d'avoir convié la Banque
de France à cette audition conjointe
dédiée aux enjeux relatifs au ce que
l'on appelle communément les monnaies
virtuelles dont dont le Bitcoin est sans
doute la l'exemple plus connu du du
grand public avant de de de traiter
directement les questions qui ont été
posées par monsieur le Président je
voudrais souligner en introduction que
le terme de monnaie ou de moyen de
paiement appliqué au au Bitcoin est
largement un abus de langage pour des
raisons à la fois économiques et
juridiques en effet selon une définition
économique généralement admise la
monnaie est un actif qui remplit trois
fonctions d'unité de compte d'instrument
d'échange et de réserve de valeur les
bitcoins et les autres dispositifs
similaires ne répondent que très
partiellement et imparfaitement à cette
définition de la monnaie en effet s'il
fournissent euh une unité compte d'une
part leur fonction d'échange est limitée
au seuls commerçant principalement sur
internet ayant pris volontairement
l'engagement qu'ils peuvent remettre en
cause à n'importe quel moment d'accepter
les bitcoins en règlement des biens et
des services et d'autre part leur
fonction de réserve de valeur est pour
le moins in
certainertaine leur convertibilité en en
monnaie et en cours légal est aléatoire
et leur valeur très fortement variable
en outre l'émission et la gestion de
Bitcoin ne relève pas du champ des
moyens de paiement reconnus par notre
code monétaire et financier et régulé à
ce titre il ne relève pas en particulier
de la monnaie électronique à laquelle on
pourrait tenter de les assimiler car ils
ne sont pas émis contre la remise de
fonds il ne bénéficie pas de ce fait
d'une garantie de remboursement au paè
dans la monnaie qui à cours légale
c'est-à-dire l'euro émis par les banques
centrales de l'Eurosystème ou dans les
monnaaies de banque qui lui sont
strictement liées c'est-à-dire celles
émise par les institutions bénéficiant
d'un statut d'établissement de crédit ou
d'émetteur de monnaie électronique
toutefois du fait de l'apparition de
plateforme permettant l'achat et la
vente d'unités de comptte virtuel comme
le Bitcoin contre la monnaie y en cours
légal ou reliée à celle-ci un nombre
croissant d'utilisateurs peuvent
acquérir ces unités de compte virtuell
de plus du fait de la faiblesse du coût
d'utilisation de ces unités de compte
virtuel certains pourraient être tentés
d'y voir une alternative attractive aux
monnaaies et moyens de paiement dont
l'émission et la gestion est régulé en
particulier pour régler des transactions
sur
Internet une telle perspective ne peut
laisser indifférent une banque centrale
comme la Banque de France chargée par le
législateur de s'assurer de la sécurité
des systèmes et des moyens de paiement
car elle pourrait conduire à une
fragilisation de notre système de
paiement sous l'effet du développement
de des dispositifs les moins 10 ans en
matière de sécurité source de risque
pour leurs utilisateurs et pour notre
économie de façon plus générale donc la
sensibilisation des utilisateurs de
monnaie virtuelle comme les Bitcoin au
dangers associés à leur utilisation est
particulièrement nécessaire et
importante c'est pourquoi la Banque de
France a comme d'autres banques
centrales et autorités publiques en
Europe en Asie et aux États-Unis publié
le 5 décembre 2013 un document dans
lequel elle soulligne en partie
particulier deux de ces dangers le
premier est que de par leur caractère
anonyme les monnaies virtuelles comme le
Bitcoin peuvent être utilisé pour
contourner les règles relatives à la
lutte contre le blanchiment de capitaux
et le financement du
terrorisme je développerai pas ce point
pense d'autres d'autres intervenants
aujourd'hui ce matin le le feront le
second danger est financier pour leur
détenteurs et cela pour au moins deux
raisons la première c'est et qu'aucune
autorité ne veille à la mise en place
des conditions nécessaires pour assurer
la sécurité des coffresforts
électroniques qui permettent le stockage
des unités de comptte virtuel tels que
les bitcoins dans ce contexte les
détenteurs n'ont aucun recours en cas de
vol de ses unités de compte par des
pirates
informatiques deuxème raison c'est que
la convertibilité en monnaie ayant cours
légal qui est nécessaire pour tirer les
bénéfices d'une spéculation sur
l'évolution de leur valeur n'est pas
garantie ainsi les les investisseurs ne
peuvent récupérer leurs gain que si
d'autres utilisateurs désirent accur
acquérir les unités de compte virtuel le
système peut donc à tout moment
s'effondrer lorsque les investisseurs
veulent dénouer leur position mais se
trouve détenteurs d'avoir devenu
illiquide un un commerçant ne pourra
donc pas accepter de manière
significative les paiements en unité de
compte virtuel sans s'exposer à des
risques substantiels de liquidité
financier opérationnel il en est de même
pour les consommateurs en outre ces
derniers qui disposent en réglant leurs
transactions en euros des garantie
associé aux moyens de paiement couvert
par la directive concernant les services
de paiement notamment le le
remboursement en cas de paiement non
autorisé ne peuvent bien évidemment pas
se prévaloir d'une garantie équivalente
dans le cas d'utilisation des monnaies
virtuelles donc je voudrais pour
conclure mon mon intervention souligner
que cette prise de conscience des
caractéristiques et des dangers liés à
l'utilisation des monnaaies virtuelles
qui n'en font pas de parfait substitut à
la monnaie légale et au moyens de
paiement scripturaux apparaît d'autant
plus nécessaire qu'il existe aujourd'hui
des solutions non seulement sûres mais
également efficace de paiement sur
internet et je rappellerai à ce titre
les efforts entrepris en France pour
renforcer la sécurité des paiements par
carte sur internet par la mise en œuvre
de dispositifs
d'authentification renforcé sous
l'impulsion notamment de l'Observatoire
de la sécurité des cartes de paiement
effort relayés désormais au niveau
européen par le projet de révision de la
directive sur les services de paiement
et les recommandations du Forum européen
sur la sécurité des moyens de paiement
s'appelle
scurep je vous remercie pour votre
attention je reste à votre disposition
merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur permettez-moi en m'exprimant
comme monsieur tout le monde de vous
poser une question toute simple
peut-être un peu frustre mais à laquelle
peut-être vous pourriez tâcher de
répondre par oui ou par non est-ce que
le Bitcoin c'est de la fausse
monnaie je je répondrai en disant par
ouiou par
non pardonnez-moi je vous provoque un
peu ça n'est pas de la monnaie je
répondrai à ah voilà ce n'est pas de la
monnaie donc d alors que c'est pas de la
monnaie ça peut la notion de fausse
monnaie a une connotation très
particulière donc pour ça que je je ne
veux pas utiliser cette expression mais
ça n'est pas de la monnaie c'était le
premier point de mon intervention au
sens où on l' défini habituellement
merci infiniment de vous être prêté au
jeu alors je me tourne vers monsieur
Grandval vous vous êtes unexert
praticien de de de cette chose n'est-ce
pas que l'on ne va pas nommer qui n'est
pas de la monnaie et qui circule qui
semble-t-il se se développe et et la
société que vous avez fondée pemium est
une des premières start-up françaises
qui élabore des solutions de paiement en
Bitcoin donc pouvez-vous nous expliquer
comment ça se passe nous apporter votre
vision de ce de ce sujet alors est-ce un
marché porteur est-ce une
niche en terme de de de de de
développement du secteur numérique
est-ce que c'est vraiment un levier
essentiel est-ce que cette chose va être
créatrice
d'emploi comment mesurer tout
cela les les les agents dans les
transaction ils trouent-il ils
trouveront-ils leur compte enfin est-ce
que vous pouvez nous aider sinon à à
toucher cette chose qui est par
définition virtuelle mais du moins à
essayer de
comprendre ce qu'elle est réellement et
et si elle est vertueuse ou vicieuse ou
les deux à la fois comme sans doute
chacun d'entre
nous alors
allez-y merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les sénateur je vous
remercie pour votre invitation dans les
5 minutes qui me sont imparties au
démarrage je vais essayer de vous
présenter ce que Bitcoin et pas
forcément les avantages les opportunités
mais vraiment ce qu'est Bitcoin de notre
point de vue
je n'ai pas pu projeter ma présentation
donc vous avez
normalement des documents qui vous ont
été remis je vous propose qu'on les
passe assez rapidement puisque 5 minutes
le délai est assez court alors Bitcoin
effectivement ce n'est pas une monnaie
Bitcoin c'est avant tout une technologie
et Bitcoin c'est une technologie qui est
libre et qui existe depuis plus de 5 ans
maintenant elle a été spécifiée en 2008
et mise en activité en 2009 en janvier
2009 Bitcoin c'est une une technologie
et plus précisément c'est un protocole
ce protocole technique définit deux
choses à la fois un réseau de
transaction sur Internet complètement
décentralisé Peer To per et Open Source
sont des mots à la mode et techniques
mais qui ont des implications très
importantes et en même temps Bitcoin
c'est l'unité de compte qui circule sur
ce réseau je ne parle pas de monnaie où
on en parlera après de façon plus rapide
en disant que c'est une monnaie
électronique peut-être même si ça n'a
pas la la définition légale mon
électronique c'est une unité de compte
qui circule sur ce réseau parler de
Bitcoin en ne parlant que de l'unité de
compte c'est oublieré la moitié du sujet
qui est le réseau de transaction
électronique et Bitcoin est d'ailleurs
défini ainsi comme un réseau comme un
système de paiement électronique ça n'a
jamais été défini comme une monnaie
c'est un système de paiement
électronique ce système a de la valeur
pour deux raisons d'une part le Réseau
existe aujourd'hui avec un nombre
d'utilisateurs importants avec une
puissance de calcul informatique
distribué très importante avec une
résilience forte et une sécurité qui
s'accroit de jour en jour face à ça une
des caractéristiques de l'unité de
compte Bitcoin c'est qu'elle est émise
en quantité limitée ce qui fait de
Bitcoin une unité de compte rare qu'on
pourrait assimiler à une action d'un
réseau Bitcoin qui est un réseau libre
on est là face à un statut un peu
hybride de de cette unité de
compte sur la slide
2 je vous présente ici la façon dont
sont opérés les paiements
électroniques le système que vous voyez
en haut à gauche c'est un système à
quatre coins qui est le système de
fonctionnement des paiements
électroniques de manière classique par
carte bancaire qui faisant intervenir un
marchand et un porteur et au-dessus
d'eux la banque du marchand et la banque
du porteur ce système de paiement est
fondé sur le
prélèvement du montant à payer sur le
compte du porteur cette
mécanique est celle qui implique
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de fraude
au paiement par carte puisque pour tout
type de paiement je suis obligé de
révéler l'ensemble de mes information
bancaire de paiement pour procéder à un
quelconque paiement qu'il soit de 5 € ou
de 1000 € je vais livrer les mêmes
informations après je dois faire
confiance au système et au garanties
qu'il apporte pour que seul le montant
du paiement soit prélevé et une seule
fois le système à tris à TR trois
éléments que vous voyez c'est un système
de paiement privatif de type American
Express ou American Express c'est à la
fois le prestataire du marchand et du
porteur on n pas deux banques dans ce
cadrel et enfin on a les systèmes qu'on
appelle de paère à paère aujourd'hui
souvent galvudé puisque on parle
généralement de paère à per pour des
systèmes privatifs donc avec un tiers de
confiance Bitcoin est la première
instanation d'un réseau véritablement de
paire à paire sans tiers de confiance au
milieu la confiance étant distribué à
l'ensemble des participants au
réseau
j'approfondis j'ai pas beaucoup de temps
je vais passer je ne passe pas sur les
slides 3 et 4 qui décrivent comment sont
réalisé des transactions sur le réseau
Bitcoin je voudrais simplement souligner
que le protocole Bitcoin étant un
protocole libre l'ensemble de la
technologie appliquée est auditable par
tout le monde et cela fait 5 ans
désormais que tout le monde audite cette
technologie et que tout le monde est
tombé d'accord pour dire que la
technologie était extrêmement sûre et
extrêmement vertueuse donc si vous
voulez on pourra lors d'une autre séance
approfondir ces sujets techniques le
point d'après présente la vision de
Bitcoin de pemium en tant que
technologie
innovante nous assimilons
Bitcoin à la même mesure que internet
l'email ou la voix sur IP ces
technologies sont des technologies
libres qui en leur temps on bouleversé
de nombreuses habitudes qui en leur
temps ont toutes été décriées c'est pas
surveillé par la NSU non
qui qui sont toutes Aujourd'hui
surveillées mais non régulé car non
régulaes car totalement libre mais
toutes surveillé
euh Bitcoin aujourd'hui c'est la
première instantiation d'une technologie
libre dans le domaine du paiement
électronique ça n'avait jamais eu lieu
jusqu'à présent et c'est la première
fois qu'un protocole technique libre
permet de réaliser des transactions de
paiement électronique ça devrait être un
point suffisant pour s'arrêter et
considérer que cette technologie est
peut-être à l'origine d'opportunités
importantes dans le domaine du paiement
comme l'email l'a été dans le domaine
des des communications ou la voix sur IP
dans le domaine des
télécommunications beaucoupe non non
vous n'aviez pas terminé pardonnez-moi
excusez-moi comme peut-être 2
minuteszy le point d'après le d'près
vous vous vous présente un certain
nombre de moyens de paiement
électronique dont vous avez peut-être
entendu parler aujourd'hui je citerai
Paypal que tout le monde connaît et
aujourd'hui en France naissent de
nombreux moyens de paiement électroniqu
à initiative de banque tel que pb
ou d'autres d'autres systèmes de
paiement tous ces systèmes de paiement
ont un point en commun c'est cela
d'après c'est qu'ils sont tous
privatifs aujourd'hui si vous êtes un
porteur d'un moyen de paiement paypal ou
un porteur d'un moyen de paiement
byister par les opérateurs télécom ou pb
par trois banques vous ne pouvez pas
vous payer les uns les autres vous
parlez la même monnaie vous êtes dans le
même pays avec les mêmes opérateurs
technologiques des banques communes qui
dialoguent ensemble mais vous ne pouvez
pas avec ces moyens de paiement échanger
les uns avec les autres c'est ce qui
génère aujourd'hui un accès très limité
à ces moyens de paiement et un
développement visiblement voué à
l'échec il y a 30 ans en France a été
créé le groupement carte bancaire qui a
eu un mérite unique dans le monde entier
c'est de développer l'usage de la carte
bancaire en France grâce à
l'interbancarité et au fait qu'on ne se
pose pas la question aujourd'hui en
étant client d'une banque avec une carte
et lorsqu'on va chez un marchand qui est
dans une autre banque de savoir si on va
pouvoir payer chez lui c'est ce qu' a
permis carte bancaire aujourd'hui
réaliser un groupement carte bancaire
dans le cadre des moyens de paiement
électroniques serait un effort
insurmontable pour qu'il soit réalisé à
l'échelle au moins européenne sinon c
n'aurait pas de sens
pour promouvoir l'interopérabilité des
moyens de paiement il faut s'adosser sur
des technologies et libre qui pluser
pour que tout le monde soit d'accord sur
la technologie qui est utilisée Bitcoin
peut-être cette technologie et donc nous
le considérons comme une passerelle et
comme un moyen d'interopérabilité
entre les moyens de paiement au bénéfice
des porteurs et des marchands et donc
indirectement des banques et des tirs de
confiance sur les systèmes de PAI vir
construire des solutions adossé à ce
protocole pour
finir je vais passer directement au
dernier slide qui présente Bitcoin
central Bitcoin central est le cœur de
notre activité aujourd'hui chez pemium
il s'agit d'une place de marché sur
laquelle des acheteurs et des vendeurs
qu'il soi particulierers ou
professionnels peuvent acheter ou vendre
des
bitcoins faisant de Bitcoin central une
passerelle de paiement entre les euros
et le réseau Bitcoin et inversement
cette place de marché fonctionne en
partenariat avec un établissement de
paiement qui est un organisme agréé par
la Banque de France qui pourra nous en
parler peut-être tout à
l'heure autorisé à à exercer des
activités de paiement électronique pour
notre part il réalise la tenue de compte
de nos clients en euros dans le respect
des règles prudentielles de connaissance
des clients et avec donc une
connaissance du client très forte dès le
premier centime d'euros sur chacune des
transactions la sécurité chez Bitcoin
central est un point majeur et nous
pratiquons une politique de stockage des
Bitcoin de nos clients à 100 % hors du
réseau c'est c'est un point un petit peu
complexe qu'on abordera peut-être tout à
l'heure et enfin notre territoire pour
Bitcoin central c'est l'Europe euh
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de marché
français le marché Bitcoin il est
majoritairement américain en Europe il
est majoritairement nord-européen euh
forcé de constater qu'en France euh il
est le moins développé de des pays des
pays européens ou presque donc il est de
notre devoir et c'est un enjeu important
pour nous de développer notre activité
partout en Europe pour faire émerger un
acteur européen majeur dans le domaine
du paiement électronique de demain qui
s'appuie sur une réglementation
française et européenne euh depuis
l'origine je vous remercie merci
beaucoup de cette présentation
et puis-je également vous poser deux
question question très simple à plein
des réponses très breeves première
question a-t-on une idée du volume des
transactions annuelles en France sur cet
instrument alors nous avons une idée
nous en tant que opérateur de l'activité
sur notre place de marché en revanche il
est difficile d'estimer le volume
d'activité en France à proprement parler
donc ça je nuris pas je n'aurai pas de
chiffre ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les
acteurs les porteurs françaisou les
utilisateurs français de Bitcoin ne sont
pas don à un usage en France aujourd'hui
il l'utilise majoritairement sur des
pays étrangers en revanche on assiste de
plus en plus à un intérêt croissant des
marchands français d'cord ok deuxème
question toujours réponse très simple
très clairire lapidaire vous nous parlez
de Bitcoin central de l'architecture du
système du réseau il y a sans doute des
moyens puissants qui permettent à tout
cela de fonctionner ça appartient à qui
ça rapporte à qui qui c'est déclaré où
alors le système n'appartient à personne
d'autre qu'à tous ses
utilisateurs le système email
n'appartient à personne le système
Bitcoin n'appartient à personne il
appartient à tous ses utilisateurs
euh et donc la valeur du réseau comme je
disais tout à l'heure elle est
uniquement fondée sur le nombre
d'utilisateurs et l'usage qu'ils font de
ce réseau en ça appartient à personne
mais quand même les profits
appartiennent aux grands opérateurs
internationaux qui utilisent ces canaux
alors ça c'est pas du bénévolant les
profits les profits liés au réseau
Bitcoin à proprement parler viennent
uniquement servir le les processeurs du
réseau Bitcoin ce sont des profits
internes au réseau en revanche sur ce
réseau se construisent des activités
commerciales comme la nôtre qui
effectivement ont vocation à générer des
profits dans leurs activités mais le
réseau Bitcoin de façon autonome génère
des profits exclusivement au bénéfice
des processeurs du réseau qui sont des
paires dans le réseau pire à paire merci
beaucoup d'avoir bien voulu jouer le jeu
je me tourne à présent vers monsieur
Cornu vous êtes directeur scientifique
de la Fondation Internet nouvelle
génération laquelle est un think
tank cercle de réflexion de recherche
qui réfléchit sur les transformations
numériques et dans ce travail vous
faites participer de nombreux acteurs
publics et privés alors de votre point
de vue est-ce que tout ça est important
ou
anecdotique structurant
ou non y y a-t-il péril y y a-t-il
chance dans quelle
proportion merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les sénateurs merci de
m'accueillir alors depuis 3 ans à peu
près nous avons fait un travail sur ce
qu'on appelé l'innovation
monétaire avec 160 personnes donc qui
sont des banquiers des économies
des innovateurs ou de simples citoyens
et nous avons cherché à comprendre
quelles étaient effectivement les
opportunités et les
risques le biaet que je vais prendre est
celui de l'innovation c'estàdire que
nous avons nous créons actuellement de
la valeur par l'innovation c'est une
chose il existe un certain d'innovation
alors technologie de service aujourd'hui
même l'innovation technologique n'est
pas suffisante aujourd'hui l'innovation
économique dont fait partie l'innovation
des alors je vais pas utiliser le terme
de monnaie mais des mécanismes de type
monétaire pour être un peu plus précis
et bien présente un certain
d'opportunités pour rendre possible
d'autres types d'innovation comme toutes
les innovations par exemple biologiques
et bien elles peuvent comporter des
risques et donc il faut comprendre à
quel moment il est nécessaire de laisser
passer des tests et quels sont les
risques par contre encourus de manière à
ce que l'on puisse à un moment donné
choisir effectivement ce que l'on
souhaite ou non par rapport à ça je
pense qu'il faut distinguer plusieurs
choses et je vais essayer d'élargir le
propos de Bitcoin et même peut-être des
monas virtuelles puceque le mot virtuel
lui-même n'est pas forcément une
caractéristique suffisante loin de là on
a parlé tout à l'heure monsieur Grandval
parlait effectivement de monnaie paèire
à paire ou de monnaie libre ou de choses
comme ça en fait il existe un certain
nombre de monnaaies qui sont différentes
que l'on va appeler complémentaires dans
un premier temps tout d'abord il y a des
monnaies effectivement de type non
économique comme les fameux cell les
systèmes d'échang locaux qui posent un
certain nombre de questions qui ont déjà
par par ailleurs été abordées euh dans
dans différentes instances des monnaaies
de réputation qui permettent que si je
vous trouve sympathique et bien je vous
donne un toolard ou alors un exploracur
qui sont des monnaies qui finalement
posent relativement peu de questions
mais qui permettent de faciliter les
fonctionnements des réseaux sociaux et
ont très peu d'impact de monétaire même
si on appelle ça monnaie à titre
justement pas tout à fait juste ou même
plus récemment les données qui sont des
mécanismes non plus pour faciliter
l'échange comme les comme le sera les
monnaaies mais mécanismes pour faciliter
le don ça c'est une chose mais ce qui va
nous intéresser évidemment c'est les
mécan c'est les mécanismes monétaires
qui eux vont avoir tras aux échanges
éventuellement aux échanges commerciaux
alors il y a effectivement les monnaaies
locales complémentaires qui sont elles
réduites réduisent le champ de l'échange
à un territoire comme le sol violette à
Toulouse l'éol à Brest à différents
endroits
euh il présente un certain nombre de
caractéristiques aussi et puis des
monnaies affectées qui elles vont
réduire au contraire non plus le
territoire mais ce que l'on en fait je
vais vous prendre un exemple très rapide
à Curitiba au Brésil et bien une monnaie
vous ne pouvez la la cette monnaie là
vous pouvez la gagner que en triant vos
déchets et vous ne pouvez dépensé que
dans les transports en commun et cette
petite monnaie qui finalement représente
l'équivalent d'une masse monétaire
insignifiante a fait des changements de
transformation énormes et des économie à
curitba gigantesque au point de devenir
la capitale verte du Brésil donc pour
vous montrer que la Pact n'est pas
simplement que sur la masse monétaire et
troisièm et celui qui va nous intéresser
c'est ce que j'appellererai des monnaes
alternatives qui ne se limitent pas
forcément qu'à l'échange mais qui
peuvent avoir un impact et particul en
particulier pourquoi pas investir prêter
ou pour spéculer ou autre chose dedans
on y trouve des monnaaies un peu plus
plus ancienne comme le vir Suisse qui
permet par exemple en Suisse de
d'échanger lorsque la monnaie le franc
suisse n'est plus suffisant depuis 1933
aujourd'hui ça représente 25 % des PME
suisses 90000 PME et ça représente
aujourd'hui une possibilité pour ces PME
d'échanger même en en période de crise
et on dit de temps en temps que c'est
une monnaie plus facile à gagner plus
difficile à dépenser mais aujourd'hui
vous pouvez acheter votre maison env
avec une particularité justement très
différente par rapport à ce qu'on nous a
présenté sur bitco c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de conversion c'estàd un virire égale un
franc suisse mais il est absolument
impossible de convertir et donc c'est
bien un système totalement séparé
d'autres systèmes comme le SK en Italie
ou le le le Red tircœur solidario en
Argentine qui a eu un impact assez
marginal jusqu'à temps qu'il a la crise
en Argentine où là ça a eu un impact
majeur pour permettre aux gens de
survivre et puis la monnaie est
redevenueel un épiphénomène par la suite
alors ces monnaai évidemment le côté
virtuel a permis simplement de faciliter
le développement et particulier de
monnaie un peu plus ayant des
particularités un peu plus nouvelles un
peu plus intéressantes un peu plus
innovant Bitcoin en fait partie de la
même manière que open UDC frycon icon
bref un certain nombre de monnais et
donc je vais essayer de de vous proposer
d'avoir trois critères euh pour essayer
d'analyser une monnaie non pas pour
décider il faut oui non c'est monnaie
c'est bien mais plutôt pour dire nous
avons probablement besoin d'innovation
monétaire pour faciliter le reste de
l'innovation et créer de la valeur mais
nous devons être conscients des risques
ces trois critères sont d'abord le poids
dans la masse monétaire euh qu'est-ce
que ça représente si on fait si on fait
rien effectivement si on interdit tous
ces monis là et bien on aura simplement
pas d'innovation mais est-ce que ça pose
un problème par rapport à la politique
monétaire par exemple deuxième question
la question de transparence alors on a
abord la question du blanchiment mais il
y a une autre question derrière c'est
celle de la taxation et donc du
financement de la collectivité s'il y a
pas de transparence évidemment on aura
un petit problème pour financer la
collectivité donc qu'est-ce quel est le
niveau de transparence ou non et troème
espèce c'est la dérive spéculative la
spéculation est une bonne chose ça
spéculer ça veut dire prévoir mais
lorsque la spéculation sur la monnaie
devient supérieur à la spéculation sur
les biens effectivement on peut avoir un
problème problème qui n'est pas limité
ni à Bitcoin ni à des Mones
complémentaires mais que nous
connaissons dans notre propre monnaie
actuellement et donc et la l'autre
aspect de de des rifes spéculative
évidemment est dans le change
effectivement et dans l'instabilité qu'
peut y avoir entre différentes monnaies
alors si maintenant je ref je me
refocalise un petit peu sur sur Bitcoin
et sur un certain nombre de Cees types
de monnaie euh qui sont que je vais
qualifier de virtuel mais aussi de
décentralisé justement pour répondre à
votre question monsieur le Président sur
la le côté euh s euh qui à qui ça
appartient et bien la masse monétaire
aujourd'hui va être limitée à terme à 21
millions de Bitcoin les quatre premières
années euh il y a euh 2,6 millions de
Bitcoin qui sont créés par an 2050
toutes les 10 minutes nous sommes dans
la 5e année et bien il y en a deux fois
moins maintenant et donc pendant les
quatre prochaines années et bien au lieu
d'en créer
2,6 millions de Bitcoin par an on en
créera 1,3 et puis dans les 4 années
suivantes encore moins jusqu'à tant
qu'on arrive à 21 million de Bitcoin
alors vous allez me dire ça représente
quoi puisque il y a une conversion entre
entre monnaie alors j'ai fait un petit
calcul aujourd'hui nous sommes à peu
près à 12 millions de Bitcoin en
circulation aujourd'hui début 2014 ça
représente au cours actuel 7 milliards
d'euros sur l'ensemble de la planète
alors ça représente quand même une somme
significative plus significative que le
sol violette qui représente à peu près
20000 € c'est représente aussi si on
s'amusait deun façon totalement
caricaturale à dire tiens les échanges
de la France dans le monde représentent
10 % ce qui est complètement
caricaturale et bien ça représenterait
0,3 pour 1000 du PIB français alors
c'est à la fois beaucoup c'est à la fois
peu ça est-ce que ça a un impact sur la
les les politiques monétaires c'est une
chose à voir et la deuxième question qui
se pose c'est que cette cette valeur de
masse change en fonction du cours du
Bitcoin si je prends je me projette en
2040 moment où euh Bitcoin aura fini de
créer des nouveaux Bitcoin et donc il y
en aura plus de nouveau avec cette somme
fixe si je prends le cours
d'introduction en 2009 et bien ça
représentait 80 millions d'euros donc
somme assez insignifiante aujourd'hui en
2014 ça représente 10 milliards ça ça
représentera à terme 10 milliards mais
au cours de 2040 je suis évidemment
incapable de vous le dire donc ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui j'aurais tendance à
dire que sur ce premier semain le
l'impact sur le poids de la masse mon
ire dans la dans l'ensemble de la masse
monétaire pour quelque chose qui n'est
pas qualifié de monnaie mais qui malgré
tout a un impact et bien est
insignifiant mais pourrait ne pas le
devenir donc simplement une chose à
surveiller deuxième aspect la
transparence alors il faut bien
comprendre que le côté paèire à paèire
est donc crypté concerne les
utilisateurs les personnes les agents
qui achètent et vendent des Bitcoin par
contre les transactions elles-même sont
transparentes et ouvertes actuellement
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
en terme
de de blanchiment effectivement on a un
petit une petite question qui se pose
c'est c'est pas tellement la transaction
qui est importante mais qui l'imet et
qui la reçoit donc là on a une
difficulté qui reste à analyser en terme
de si je reprends mes autres aspects en
terme de taxation et de financement de
la
collectivité on a là on pourrait se dire
bah tiens finalement toutes les
taxations c'est super je les voir donc
je peux taxer mettre de la TVA par
exemple dessus pourquoi pas sauf que
évidemment je ne sais pas les tinataire
et donc je sais pas dans quel pays faire
la taxation donc on a une difficulté qui
est une difficulté qu'on va retrouver de
plus en plus souvent dans un monde
internet de d'avoir une taxation
nationale évidemment avec une question
de d'outils et de protocole et
d'innovation qui elle-même est de plus
en plus international donc ça pose des
questions nouvelles sur lequel je suis
pas là pour donner des réponses mais
plutôt pour essayer de d'orienter les
questions trisème aspect la spéculation
ou plutôt la dérive spéculative puisque
c'est pas la spéculation qui est en
enjeu mais la dérive spéculative
il y a deux choses qui me semblent
importantes et je terminerai par là
c'est que la première chose finalement
puisqu'on produit de moins en moins de
Bitcoin c'est une monnaie qui comme le
disait mon collègue est une monnaie
rare mais malgré tout et bien lorsque
vous achetez des bitcoins lorsque vous
achetez des Bitcoin en 2000 en 2009 et
bien vous aviez toutes les 10 minutes 50
Bitcoin qui étaient affectés à quelqu'un
au hasard parmi le l'ensemble c'est
celui dont le ordinateur faisait le
calcul pour les autres alors c'est un
système crypté donc sécurisé ça je je
pense la question évidemment c'est que
quand il y a pas beaucoup de monde et
bien on recevait plus souvent 50 Bitcoin
et c'est comme ça que la masse monétaire
de Bitcoin est créée et puis maintenant
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de monde sur
Bitcoin et bien je reçois moins souvent
et non plus 50 mais si vous avez compris
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
cette fois la moitié puisque depuis le
1er janvier et bien on en est à 25
Bitcoin toutes les 10 minutes donc ça
veut dire que les premiers entrant sont
sur un système euh effectivement où ils
sont favorisés par rapport au nouveaux
alors là il y a il y a un débat
actuellement pour savoir si c'est une
chaîne de Ponzi ou non il y a des
arguments pour il y a des arguments
contre c'est clairement pas une chaîne
de ponie contrôlé est-ce que c'est un
système qui malgré tout favorise les
premiers par rapport au suivant ça c'est
quelque chose à analyser alors c'est le
premier aspect spéculatif mais qui est
je dirais inter terme à Bitcoin si
Bitcoin était simplement un système
fermé sur lui-même qui permet de faire
des échanges en dehors des monnaaies
classiques un peu comme le son certains
monnaie comme le vir de cité ou des
monnaaies complémentaires deuxième chose
il se trouve que Bitcoin est donc un
système qui permet la convertibilité il
y a donc des bourses comme on l'a vu
avec premium des places de marché les
virements pour être plus sécurisé
effectivement parce que on a un système
un peu comme le où à partir du moment
c'est fait de façon automatique oui de
façon automatique et bien on va avoir un
système qui va ressembler un peu à
l'échange de de billets et bien il y a
on naccepte pas cartes Paypal mais on
peut effectivement faire des virements
aujourd'hui juste un chiffre pour
terminer la le le système l'inflation
donc de de la valeur de Bitcoin par
rapport à à l'euro est de 900 % en 2013
ou de 618 % si j'ai repris les chiffres
du 17 septembre 2013 à hier 14 janvier
2000 2014 donc on voit que d'une part la
valeur augmente par rapport à l'euro
dans le temps et que le nombre de
Bitcoin par contre diminue donc deux
questions
encore une fois à se poser en terme de
dérive spéculative ce qui me semble très
important et ce que je le seul message
que j'aimerais vous passer c'est que
nous avons absolument besoin
d'innovation et que l'innovation
technologique ne suffit plus
l'innovation service est nécessaire mais
il faut aller plus loin l'innovation
économique dans les modèle économique
dans les nouveaux modes de financement
comme le financement par la foule ou
comme les monnaies innovantes où les
mécanismes monétaires innovantes sont
indispensables mais il nous faut des
critères comme ceux que j'ai proposé par
exemple pour analyser les meilleures
innovations et celles qui nous
permettront d'aller dans dans l'avenir
merci merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur Scientifique j'ai très mal
présidé j'ai été très bienveillant je
vous ai laisser parler le double du
temps qui était prévu bon il ne faudrait
surtout pas que les autres
intervenants en fassent une règle
générale bien entendu mais c'était très
concret et et c'est pour cela que je
vous ai laissé poursuivre alors monsieur
le rapporteur général qu'est-ce que tout
toutes ces communications tous ces
éléments vous inspirent et ben monsieur
le Président moi je trouve que ce sujet
est d'une extrême importance
euh monsieur Grandval a tout à l'heure
évoquer euh les cartes bancaires et nous
a fait remonter 30 ans en arrière et
pour quiconque se penche sur ce sujet
des cartes bancaires il constatera en
relisant les débats de l'époque qu'il y
avait plus que des réticences à
l'utilisation élargie et systématiser
des cartes bancaires il y a eu un grand
débat euh euh dans le monde il y a un
grand débat dans notre pays il y a eu
des résistances il y a eu euh euh bien
bon nombre d'interventions euh ici et là
qui euh mettaient en en exerg les
dangers les risques que tout ça lesit
comporté et il y avait dans notre pays
beaucoup de commerçants qui refusaient
les paiements en carte bancaire euh donc
on a euh là euh un rapprochement qui
nous permet bien d'identifier
le fait que l'innovation en ce qui
concerne les actes économiques et en
particulier les actes liés au paiement
pose assez naturellement des problèmes
et ceci est encore conforté par tout ce
qui entoure le sujet aujourd'hui
puisqu'on nous a parlé monsieur beau
nous a parlé de coffrefort électronique
et vous avez vousmême parlé à l'instant
des dérives des spéculations ce sont de
nombreux mots qui intervienent dans la
discussion et qui démontre s'il en était
besoin qu'on est au cœur d'une
préoccupation qui est fondamentale à
notre société mais malgré ceci malgré
ces interrogations on a le sentiment que
cette
innovation apporte une réponse positive
parce que la théorie économique nous
enseigne depuis au moins 50 ans que
lorsque l'on améliore la situation sur
les coûts de
transaction on crée une dynamique
économique porteuse d'avenir et j'ai le
sentiment ici que c'est bien de ça qu'il
s'agit et tout à l'heure la question
qu'on vous posit qui sont les
bénéficiaires où tombent les royalties
vous nous avez bien dit que c
internaliser que ce sont les acteurs qui
eux-mêmes bénéficient de l'amélioration
des coûts de transaction et qu'en
l'occurrence c'est de dès lors une
logique économique tout à fait porteuse
d'avenir mais
pour nos nos trois intervenants qui vont
suivre je voulais ayant dit
cela préciser aussi
que certains estiment tout de même et on
va aller plus loin dans l'interrogation
que les Bitcoin aujourd'hui sont
présenté comme la monnaie des mafias
entre guillemets hein bien entendu mais
c'est une expression que je n'ai pas
inventé et dès lors peut-être
puisque nous sommes ici au Parlement et
dans une préoccupation de régulation
bien entendu pour tout ce qui
concerneactivité économique peut-être
pourrions-nous être mieux éclairés sur
quelques sujets importants et je
m'adresse aux trois intervenants qui
vont s'exprimer est-ce qu'on peut nous
expliquer comment et pourquoi cette
monnaie est utilisée pour le blanchiment
d'argent ou pour les transaction de
drogue ou le paiement d'armes c'est
quelque chose qui revient souvent dans
les choses qu' qu'on peut lire sur ce ce
sujet
euh est-ce que le Bitcoin a permis le
développement des trafics ou bien
s'est-il substitué aux monnaaiieses que
nous
connaissons et au fond derrière Bitcoin
il y a aussi d'autres monnaies il y a
d'autres monnaies virtuelles plus
confidentielles qui seraiit plus
spécialement développé dans le but de
servir au blanchiment des activités
criminelles donc est-ce que c'est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt Bitcoin
est-ce que derrière il y a tout un
ensemble de
protocoles plus spécialisés qui autorise
d'autres
exploitations non vertueuses et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut nous dire sur ce
point et puis s'agissant du Trésor
peut-être qu'il serait bon qu'on nous
éclaire sur les réflexions en cours sur
le sujet des du Bitcoin en France et en
Europe puisque nous avons constaté que
les États avaient adopt des attitudes
fort différentes vis-à-vis du
Bitcoin la Chine a pris des dispositions
tout récemment pour un contrôle très
étroit de l'utilisation de cet
outil la
Thaïlande a mis en place une
interdiction
d'utilisation et l'Allemagne de son côté
a d'un certaine façon reconnu une forme
de statut légale
à ce mode de paiement et donc notre
questionnement est est en définitive le
suivant
euh c'est comment la législation
française peut évoluer en particulier
législation fiscale et financière par
exemple est-ce qu'on doit déclarer ses
Bitcoin à l'ISF
euh si on vend un objet contre Bitcoin
est-ce que il faut lui appliquer la TVA
et euh si euh une start-up pratique le
change Bitcoin contre euro est-ce qu'on
doit dès lors adopter le statut d'agent
de change parce qu'on est dans cette euh
pratique en définitive du point de vue
concret donc voyez euh madame messieurs
que il y a sur le plan de la régulation
nécessité d'une meilleure compréhension
de ce que sont tous les ressort de ce
nouveau dispositif qui tente à émerger
et euh que nous comprenions bien aussi
en quoi la régulation doit opérer d'une
façon tout à fait exigeante aujourd'hui
dans ce domaine voilà monsieur le
Président les questionnements je pense
qu'il peuvent guider les propos de nos
intervenants bien merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur général je
partage totalement ces ces question
et je je rappelle au moment de passer la
parole à Monsieur Garcia directeur
national du renseignement des enquêtes
douanières que selon la la Banque de
France en 2013
aux États-Unis une action judiciaire
conduite par le FBI et ayant mené à des
arrestations a été engagé contre des
fournisseur de plateformes de conversion
soupçonné de blanchiment d'argent et de
fraude fiscale et que le 2 octobre 2013
c'est donc encore très récent les
autorités judiciaires américaines ont
ainsi fermé le site internet
silcud site d'acquisition de produits
narcotiques en ligne et anonyme sur
lequel s'échangeait une importante
partie desbit coins en circulation seul
moyen de paiement accepté sur ce site
alors Monsieur Garcia et puis monsieur
Carpentier et est-ce que vous pouvez
nous est-ce que vous pouvez tout nous
dire sur ce sujet en en 5 minutes chacun
monsieur le Président merci tout vous
dire beaucoup sans doute en 5 minutes
plus difficile monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur c'est c'est
toujours une grande joie et beaucoup
d'émotion pour un si petit service
d'être devant la représentation
nationale et de s'exprimer sur un si
vaste sujet euh je suis assurément la
dernière route du Carros par rapport au
représentant de Bercy ici présent euh et
en même temps probablement sans offense
celui qui est le plus au contact de la
réalité euh merci d'avoir terminer votre
propos en citant cette remarquable
affire silcud euh à la fin de l'année
2013 il s'est passé quelque chose en
France qui évidemment n'a rien à voir
avec silcud en ceci que il n'impliquait
pas autant de service et autant de monde
qui sont intervenus aux États-Unis et en
même temps qu'il visaient une cible
infiniment plus humble que Scud nous
avons laadnrd et spécialement cyberdoine
je vous ai amené le chef de cyberdoine
ici présent pour que vous le voyez c'est
à la fois le chef et l'essentiel du
service de cyberdine puisque c'est une
poignée de personne au sein d'un service
de dnrd qui fait 700 personnes et dont
notre ministre répète à l'envie que s'il
est essentiel il n'est pas
prioritaire
en décembre
2013 nous avons réussi cyberdine a
réussi et les services de la dnrd
avec l'assistance de pmium à procéd à
l'arrestation d'un trafiquant de
stupéfiant qui vendait un produit qu'on
appelle le speed sur Internet et qui se
faisait payer en Bitcoin c'est-à-dire
qu'avec l'argent de l'État la dnrd a
acheté des bitcoins et est intervenu sur
le DIP web pour procéder à l'achat grâce
à la loi modifiée par la représentation
nationale qui nous a permis ce coup
d'achat la dnrd a acheté une petite
quantité de speed sur internet avec des
Bitcoin et comme fait toujours la douane
et principe de réalité nous travaillons
sur la marchandise l'argent et ce qui
nous aide à appréhender la marchandise
nous avons tracé cette marchandise qui
nous a permis d'intervenir dans les
locaux de la personne qui était un un un
ex excellent geek hein quelqu'un qui
maniait bien et qui travaillait bien sur
Internet et qui avait ainsi perçu tout
l'intérêt qu'il y avait à travailler sur
ce que l'on vient d'expliquer qui est
Bitcoin voilà euh alors ce que je dis
est vérifiable aujourd'hui la personne
mise en examen et bien entendu comme
toujours la douane a passé le relais à
la police judiciaire le procureur ayant
estimé que cette affaire pour
emblématique qu'elle était relevé de la
compétence de l'Office central de
répression du trafic illicde de
stupéfiant je sais pas si mes si mes 5
minutes sont dépassées je vais juste
parler du risque le risque aujourd'hui
pour nous c'est-à-dire pour la douane et
spécialement pour la dnrd il est
clairement sur les trafics d'espèces le
premier risque aujourd'hui ce sont les
espèces c'est la monnaie et c'est
l'argent nous nous sommes toujours à la
remorque d'un élément légal ou d'un
élément réglementaire qui nous permette
de mieux pénétrer les échanges espèces
et échanges internation nationaux et
échanges nationaux malgré les lois qui
imposent des transactions commerciales
par d'autres moyens des des chèqus ou
des cartes il y a toujours ce risque
essentiel présenté par les espèces le
sujet de la monnaie virtuelle et
spécialement du Bitcoin pour moi il est
de l'avenir et de l'anticipation je
pense que les dirigeants des grandes
entreprises de fraude aujourd'hui sont
de ma génération de notre génération ou
de celle immédiatement qui suit c'est
c'estàdire des gens qui ne sont pas
familiarisés et qui n'ont pas forcément
confiance le problème pour les
trafiquants le problème du Bitcoin
aujourd'hui est essentiellement la
volatilité de la devise ce sont des gens
qui sont attentifs à avoir des monnaies
dans les qu'ils peuvent stocker qui vont
parfois mettre longtemps à utiliser ou à
dépenser avec le Bitcoin le risque et et
avec les monnaieses virtuelles le risque
est évident il y a ce risque là mais et
je crois que et et le travail de
Cyberdan et le travail que nous faisons
et l'intérêt que nous avons à développ
des contacts avec les échangeurs tel
pemium c'est de préparer l'avenir et de
l'anticiper et de l'anticiper peut-être
mieux que nous n'avions anticipé la fin
du contrôle deséchanges en 88 et 89 sans
offense je rappelle que la loi de 90 qui
fond de Tracfin a été créé au sein de la
Direction générale des Douanes et que
les premiers personnels de Tracfin
étaient dédigners afin de ne pas se
trouver dans l'absence d'anticipation
nous investissons beaucoup dans la
connaissance des monnaies virtuelles et
à cet égard vous avez bien compris que
nous ne pourrions nous ne pourrons
entrer dans ce
dispositif très opaque très opaque que
par les échangeurs que par les gens qui
vont permettre fournir stocker ces
Bitcoin je vous remercie mon merci
beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur comme vous le savez le Sénat
en ce qui concerne les moyens d'enquête
et d'investigation a euh très largement
joué son rôle notamment dans le cadre de
la dernière loi de finance loi de
finance rectificative et nous sommes en
effet très conscients de la nécessité de
ne pas désarmer l'État au moment où les
zones de risque sont particulièrement
préoccupantes alors je me tourne vers
monsieur Carpentier directeur de
tracfine qui n'est plus au sein de la
Direction générale des Douanes mais mais
mais bon ceci ne l'empêche certainement
pas de faire un travail efficace
efficace je ne sais pas si mon si mon
collègue est la dernière roue du
carrosse moi je ne suis que la
roulette c'est encore pire euh nous bon
je vais avoir un propos
forcément en tout cas prudent et et je
ne dissimule pas légèrement inquiet sur
le sur le sujet sujet des monnaies
virtuelles tout d'abord je voudrais
enfin non pas rebondir mais saluer la la
clarification des concepts fait par
Monsieur Cornu parce que je crois que
c'est difficile de parler des monnaies
virtuelles en général il y a il y a il y
a plusieurs monnaies la problématique du
Bitcoin n'est pas la problématique de
Liberty Reserve c'est pas la c'est pas
la
problématique d'autres monnaaies que je
ne citerai pas ici forcément ce n'est
pas la problématique des systèmes
d'échang locaux donc il y a il y a une
vraie difficulté à à englober sous un
sous un chapeau identique des
problématiques qui sont très différentes
mais avec quand même une caractéristiqu
commune je reconnais c'est ce sont des
systèmes qui se sont inscrits en
parallèle d'un système qui jusqu'à
présent avait pour le au moins en France
et quand même dans la majorité des pays
développés un monopole de fit qui était
la monnaie légale émise par les
autorités centrales et nous avons nous
constatons depuis quelques années le
développement de systèm parallèle qui
dans un certain nombre de cas étaient
vraiment des systèmes très très très des
épiphénomènes qui étaient d'ailleurs
parfois extrêmement sympathique he je
pense notamment au système d'échanges
locaux qui ne soulevait pas tellement de
difficultés qui était aussi je rappelle
que c'est l'origine des monnaaies
virtuelles qui étaient d'abord et avant
tout des systèmes inscrits dans des
communautés notamment de gamers dans des
jeux en vidéo hein à l'origine la
plupart des monnaies virtuelles naissent
de ces systèmes liés à un certain nombre
de plateformes de jeux vidéo mais il est
vrai que depuis plusieurs depuis
quelques années nous voyons émerger
au-delà de ces cercles fermés de
communauté de gamers ou ou de ou de de
de ou de différents cercles via actuel
ou réel nous voyons émerger des vraies
monnaaies alors Tracfin a eu l'occasion
de probablement parmi les premiers je
crois au sein de l'État de s'intéresser
à ces questionsl nous en avons déjà fait
un premier élément un première analyse
lors de notre rapport annuel si mes
souvenirs sont bon en 2011 euh oui c'est
ça notre rapport annuel 2011 puisque
nous avions à l'époque déjà fait un
premier groupe de travail sur la
question où nous avions eu l'occasion
d'appeler l'attention des différentes
autorités qui ont l'heure de lire ce
rapport sur les problématiques liées à
ces à à ces questions nous sommes
actuellement en train d'animer un autre
groupe de travail qui réunit les
pouvoirs publics les les les parties
prenantes euh nécessaires des pouvoirs
publics dans ce domaine afin d'essayer
de mieux comprendre les évolutions mais
c'est c'est le système évolue
extrêmement vite et donc il faut se
tenir au courant alors à partir de là
nous on est forcément relativement
inquiet puisque le constat il est assez
simple depuis
1990 l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics
internationaux sous lesgine notamment du
Gaffi a mis en place un certain nombre
de règles de transparence et de contrôle
des transactions financières l'idée
générale était nous libéralisons les
flux financiers nous rentrons dans un
monde où il y a en principe la liberté
de circulation des capitaux cette
liberté de circulation des capitaux est
contrebalancé par un dispositif de
surveillance de ces flux de capitaux
afin de s'assurer que cette
libéralisation est utilisé à bon essant
et non pas à mauvais essant donc c'est
la création du Gaffi c'est la création
d'un ensemble extrêmement complet de
normes qui s'imposent à toute une série
d'acteurs sur les systèmes de paiement
or de fait nous voyons dans les les
dispositifs nouveaux qui apparaissent
nous voyons s'inscrire quelque chose qui
est forcément complètement dans le Black
Hole et et dans la dans dans l' légal je
vais pas dire dans l'illégal mais dans
l' légal nous n'avons pas intégré cela
dans la régulation alors je veux pas
m'élever audessus de ma condition mais
les problématiques sont beaucoup plus
larges que les problématiques de lutte
contre le blanchiment vous avez très
largement évoqué par exemple les
problématiques fiscales quel est le
statut d'un compte en Bitcoin détenu à
l'étranger mais je ne suis pas sûr que
ça a le moindre sens de dire détenu à
l'étranger quel est le sens de détenir à
l'étranger un compte un Bitcoin ça n'a
pas de sens quel est le statut ISF quel
est le statut de la TVA comment comment
enregistre-t-on en comptabilité une
transaction mais que disje en Bitcoin
mais ça peut être en Liberty Reserve ça
peut-être en n'importe quelle autre
monnaie virtuelle il faut se rappeler
qu'il y a d'autres monnaaies donc tout
cela ce sont des problématiques qui sont
qui restent très largement à ouvrir et
quelles sont les obligations de
vigilance des établist
comment doit-on surveiller est-ce que là
où votre banquier va vous poser des
questions parce qu'il est obligé de le
faire sur le dépôt en espèce ou sur un
retrait en espèce ou sur telle ou telle
transaction comment va-t-on quand même
trouver une certaine équivalence sur ce
type de transaction en monnaie virtuelle
comment va-t-on assurer l'équité
concurrentielle entre les différents
acteurs nous imposons aux acteurs soumis
à la régulation financière un certain
nombre de coûts pour surveiller ces
transactions il y a des personnes il y a
des emplois qui sont payés à temps plein
à surveiller pour le compte de la
collectivité publique les transactions
dans le monde régulé peut-on envisager
que un un monde à régulé s'inscrive sans
ces coûts en ayant les bénéfices mais
sans les coup ce sont des questions que
je pose je je je me permets pas de
répondre il y a les les autorités
ministérielles et le et le Parlement
sont là pour répondre mais je ne fais
que poser toutes ces questions je ne
veux pas être trop long donc voilà un
peu le paysage que je fais moi la seule
chose
que je peux dire c'est que c'est un
domaine dans lequel nous voyons par
construction extrêmement peu de choses
pour reprendre une image que je fais
souvent devant le Parlement le
dispositif de contrôle des flux
financiers c'est un dispositif qui
fonctionne sur des radars fixes et
mobiles c'est un peu comme la comme le
contrôle de de la vitesse les radars
actuellement sont posés sur un certain
nombre de route il se trouve qu'il y a
une autre route qui qui qui qui est
construite en parallèle sur laquelle il
y a pas de radar donc je je suis
incapable de vous dire s'il y a ou pas
des excès de vitesse on n pas mis de
radar donc la question de savoir si il y
en a ou pas je n'en sais rien alors de
temps en temps quand même nous avons vu
de trois choses vous me pardonnerez
d'être relativement discret sur les
affaires en cours nous avons eu des
sujets qui soit directement soit
indirectement touchent à la monnaie
virtuelle qui sont soit en cours
d'examen au sein du service pour
quelques affaires d'entre elles ont été
transmises à l'autorité judiciaire pour
examen plus approfondi par ailleurs nos
relations internationales nous
permettent effectivement d'être en lien
assez étroit avec un certain nombre de
pays qui ont peut-être un temps d'avance
sur ces questionsl et qui qui commence
quand même depuis quelques mois à
manifester une réelle inquiétude sur
cette économie je ne vais pas forcément
dire noir au sens négatif mais en tout
cas ignorer qui s'inscrit actuellement
dans les monnaes virtuelles et qui selon
toute probabilité a maintenant dépassé
le stade du pur anecdotique dans lequel
nous étions encore il y a quelques mois
je ne vais pas forcément dire que c'est
du macroéconomique mais nous sommes
au-delà de l'épaisseur du trait
probablement je répondrai à vos
questions après mais je crois j'ai été
suffisamment long merci infiniment
monsieur le
directeur pour votre approche lucide
bon je crois qu'on peut partager vos
questions bon on espérerait dans cette
audition aller un peu plus loin que la
formulation des questions n'est-ce pas
parce que c'est bon et maintenant je
vais me tourner vers madame Delphine
laarzit donc à vous la motion de
synthèse c'est très difficile parce que
soit on apparaît comme hyle à
l'innovation et bien entendu on est voué
aux gémonies du monde d'aujourd'hui hein
c'est c'est c'est c'est un grand péril
surtout au
Sénat
soit on on on on on
on on a une
approche particulièrement libérale et et
et allente sur le sujet mais bien
entendu au risque de tomber dans tous
les travers
qui ont été évoqué par vos prédécesseurs
alors quelle est votre
ligne merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
alors entre les roues du carrosse et les
roulettes je sais pas ce que je peux
dire je la seule femme peut-être voilà
je m'en sors par une pirhouette susciter
naturellement la symathie vous êtes tous
vous êtes tous muets voilà alors
effectivement la motion de synthèse est
difficile je crois que les points ont
été posés euh notamment tout à l'heure
une une des vraies questions et je crois
qu'elle est pas encore tranchée c'est y
y a-t-il un intérêt spécifique des ces
monnaies virtuelles en terme de coût de
transaction aujourd'hui elle se présente
avec moins de frais euh donc il peut y
avoir un intérêt sonnant et trébuchant
pour les utilisateurs et pour les
commerçants mais en contrepartieombre de
de frais qui sont pas forcément
monétaires du type
sécurité plus grande sécurité
informatique et cetera ce type de choses
le le besoin d'avoir une double
transaction donc je pense que là-dessus
euh le potentiel développement du marché
pourra nous dire si euh il y a un
véritable effet concurrentiel en tant
que moyen de paiement au sens non non
juridique du terme puisque c'est
effectivement pas un moyen de paiement
au sens du code monétaire et financier
puisque tout commerçant peut le le
refuser
euh le il y a aussi un intérêt en tant
que tel effectivement qui est pas celui
qu'on souhaite outre un aspect purement
libertarien sur lequel je m'étends pas
mais qui est effectivement un intérêt
pour des personnes qui auraient des
choses à cacher donc ça c'est pas
quelque chose qui qui nous paraît
générer des externalités positives
évidemment et puis un un deuxième point
qui est important c'est que l'aspect
spéculatif du Bitcoin qui est lié à sa
rareté et qui est lié à à au
déséquilibre entre l'offre et la demande
et l'absence de de moyen
de disons le la la la le déséquilibre
entre entre ceux qui les recherche
aujourd'hui et l'usage qu'on peut en
fait et les vendeurs pardon
limite en fait le développement du
Bitcoin dans l'ensemble des des des
caractéristiques de la monnaie et donc
ça il faut se compte c'est le paradoxe
c'est en partie à cause de cette très
forte volatilité qu'aujourd'hui le
Bitcoin n'est probablement pas une
menace pour la stabilité financière
puisque son développement est limité par
cela alors évidemment du point de vue
des pouvoirs publics ça implique une
action qui est important de pour les
pour pour les utilisateurs un commerçant
de compréhension de cette volat ité de
ce risque comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par de nibo la convertibilité
n'est pas garantie il y a un risque
opérationnel effectivement en cas de
hacking et cetera mais tout simplement
il y a un risque de volatilité donc
là-dessus il est nécessaire d'avoir une
sensibilisation ça déjà été en partie
fait notamment au niveau européen par
l'Autorité Européenne bancaire le Ba qui
a effectué une alerte au mois de au mois
de
décembre et et dans les dans les adox
les problématiques auquel on va être
confronté c'est que plus on va clarifier
les choses et les sécuriser plus on va
évidemment permettre une meilleure
diffusion de ces monnées virtuel donc il
y a là-dessus une une une tension
classique d'ailleurs entre avoir quelque
chose qui est peu sécurisé sur lequel on
averti et on sait que c'est comme ça que
ceux qui sont là-dedans sont des joueurs
et puis quelque chose plus
sécurisé ça je je ne sais pas alors si
je si je rentre un peu plus j'essaie de
rentrer plus dans le dans le si j'essaie
de rentrer plus peut-être dans dans des
pas encore des réponses j'en ai peur
mais peut-être des des orientations la
question d'une interdiction absolue je
pense qu'elle a du mal je sais pas si
c'est moi qui fait ça elle est elle est
difficile à poser en tant que tel
puisque on ne voit pas pour dans quelle
mesure on pourrait interdire quelque
chose qui serait de l'ordre du troc
entre agent privé selon des modalités
libres ou alors on a on va très loin
dans le contrôle sur sur l'activité donc
je sais pas si si on est ce qui est
possible évidemment c'est d'intervenir
en en imposant des obligations et puis
euh la piste la plus euh la plus
opérationnelle c'est probablement le
lieu de rencontre entre ces monnaaies
virtuelles et la monnaie légale et c'est
là en particulier
euh il y a une décision de justice
récente qui a confirmé
que les plateformes qui font la
conversion en monnaie légale en euro
sont tenus d'avoir une un statut de
prestataire de service de paiement
monsieur rapporteur général vous avez
employé le terme d'agent de change je
pense que le le terme qui visiblement
est celui qui est le plus adapté c'est
celui de prestataire de service de
paiement qui est un des statut qui n'est
pas établissement de crédit mais qui est
un statut spécialisé si vous voulez vous
pourrez nous donner s'il vous plaît les
références précises de cette juris
prudence euh je va si j'ai le temps de
les chercher je pourrais vous les donner
tout à l'heure euh donc ça c'est un
point c'est un point important alors
évidemment ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
là-dessus on capture tout puisqu'il peut
y avoir dans le ça peut être confirmé
par d'autres en Bitcoin des transactions
sont purement privés de gré à gré et qui
ne sont pas convertis pas pas sur des
plateformes et donc évidemment là on n
pas un on n pas un filet complet
euh comme je l'ai dit un impératif de de
sensibilisation et puis évidemment une
question importante qui est celle du
risque de blanchiment qui qui n'est pas
je crois que la traçabilité les les
techniciens de Bitcoin pensent qu'elle
est possible puisqueil y a une
traçabilité des transactions le problème
c'est que
si personne dans ce système ne demande
l'identité de la personne qui est
derrière la transaction la traçabilité
elle est utile d'un point de vue
technique elle est pas utile d'un point
de vue de lutte contre le blanchiment et
donc c'est là que avec l'intersection
des des plateformes de service de
paiement on peut au moins capturer une
partie de la problématique si on a des
acteurs et tout à l'heure monsieur
Grandval nous a expliqué que la
plateforme établissement de crédit qui
qui tient le compte effectue ces dilence
voilà euh donc donc c'est un point
important c'est c'est elles sont débattu
au niveau international des lignes
directrices du Gaffi sur les les
nouveaux moyens de paiement qui datent
maintenant un petit peu qui probablement
mériterait d'être relancé un groupe de
travail interservice que Jean-Baptiste
Carpentier a mentionné auquel nous
participons sur le plan
fiscal alors c'est une compétence qui
n'est pas celle de la direction générale
du
Trésor les travaux sont en cours en lien
entre la directionchon fiscal et mes
équipes je pense que les questions que
vous posez sont toutes pertinent
j'ajouterai celle du revenu de ce qu'on
appelle les mineurs qui sont qui qui qui
fabriquent les les Bitcoin en fait si
j'ai bien compris en pas uniquement sur
la base d'un d'un protocole inutile mais
bien parce que leur contribution est de
faire fonctionner le
système en assurant les la sécurité des
transactions grâce au modalité de calcul
mais donc avec ceci ils ont un revenu
qui qui leurit versé en en émission de
de Bitcoin donc toutes ces questions
sont pertinentes c'est il y a
probablement pas d'ensemble
vide puisque chaque revenu peut
probablement être défini mais il y a un
effort de définition à faire et je crois
qu'un certain nombre de de particuliers
ont posé des questions concrètes en
disant voilà j'ai spontanément j'ai j'ai
j'ai eu tel tel revenu en Bitcoin que
dois-je faire donc c'est ces questions
sont à l'étude et puis il y a évidemment
une question délicate qui est celle du
du contrôle la capacité à identifier
puisque dans certains cas ça peut rester
dans une sphère que Jean-Baptiste
Carpentier qualifia d'All légale et qui
n'est pas évidente non seulement à
identifier mais même à définir voilà
donc c'est ces questionsl sont sont à
l'étude et je
je reviendrons vers la direction de
législation fiscale pour avancer sur ces
sujets merci beaucoup madame le chef de
service plusieurs collègues souhaitent
s'exprimer je vous suggère que nous les
entendions successivement puis le
Rapporteur général a de nouvelles
questions peut-être dans la F
que nous adresserons au différents
membres du du panel alors Monsieur
Alberic de mangolfie a demandé la parole
en premier merci monsieur le Président
donc c'est un témoignage puisqueavec
Philippe daller comme cétait dit tout à
l'heure nous avons produit un rapport
relativement récemment sur la fiscalité
le contrôle des douanes sur le commerce
électronique et nous étions rendus à
cyberdouine donc Cyberdouane est un de
petites cellules des douanes qui peties
cellues des douanes qui fait de la
veille sur sur Internet et nous avons vu
de manière très précise le
fonctionnement du réseau Thor le réseau
Thor donc c'est un réseau auquel on
accède en téléchargeant un logiciel et
on accède ensuite à des plateformes
illégales du type silcad comme ça a été
dit à l'instant et bien sûr ce qui nous
a étonné avec philippe Dallier c'est que
sur cette plateforme où il y avait des
catégories
stupéfiant trafic d'armes assassinat on
choisissait C rubrique donc c c'estz
varié mais domaine vraiment illicite et
bien évidemment tous les paiements se
faisaient en Bitcoin donc on a été un
peu
euhté refroidi par la le caractère
vertueux du Bitcoin ça rejoint un peu ce
que ça dit donc voilà donc question
toute simple en effet pourquoi ces
plateformes utilisent le Bitcoin bon je
crois qu'on a une partie de la réponse à
la question ma question porte sur le
nombre d'utilisateurs du Bitcoin
j'entendait une émission passionnante
dans la voiture dimanche la radio et on
disait que un très petit nombre de
personnes physiques je crois que c'était
l'ORD de 500 détenaent la moitié des
bitcoins en circulation est-ce que ce
chiffre peut être confirmer combien y y
a-t-il de personnes qui dent les Bitcoin
est-ce qu'il y a une si grande
concentration sur un si faible nombre de
détenteurs merci merci beaucoup à
alberriic de Montgolfier la parole est à
Richard
j merci monsieur le Président écoutez
moi je voudrais d'abord rejoindre le
rapporteur général pour dire bienvenue à
à l'innovation on a là visiblement tout
un secteur nouveau qui est en train de
s'ouvrir que on comprend plus ou moins
bien mais c'est le but de d'audition
comme aujourd'hui de de mieux de mieux
comprendre et euh je rappelle que la
France est en retard en particulier dans
le domaine des circuits de paiement euh
tout ce qui était tout ce qui est Paypal
et cetera n'est pas en France
malheureusement même s'il y a une
initiative récente des grandes banques
d'essayer de monter un un réseau de
paiement en ligne nous nous sommes en
retard et moi j'aurais tendance à dire
nous devons pas rater de de nouvelles de
nouvelles possibilités surtout si elle
facilit les échanges et permettent de de
baisser le coût des transactions qu'il y
ait des choses illégales qui se passent
c'est pas lié à la nature du produit ça
existe partout tout ce qui a été évoqué
c'est c'est fait aussi avec des checs un
peu moins d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas
très bien mais avec du liquide ou avec
d'autres moyens de payance donc c'est
pas le moyen de paiement je dirais qui
est en cause c'est quelque chose que
malheureusement auquel malheureusement
nous aurons à faire face et que le
système soit à légal àégal c'est
l'expression que vous avez vous avez
forgé un nouvel adjectif de de dans la
langue française ce qui est bien
d'ailleurs en soit c'est pas nouveau
regardez la régulation bancaire nous
faisons des efforts énormes en matière
de régulation bancaire enfin vous
connaissez tout ça mais nous savons tous
que à côté de ça il y a un secteur non
régulé hein la la banque parallèle en
quelque sorte qui n'est pas illégal mais
qui échappe à toute réglementation alors
temps en temps nous essayons de faire
ceci pour les chambres de compensation
tout ça mais en réalité le grand volume
et donc on est au fond dans la même dans
la même situation
ce qu'il faudrait bien sûr que nous
devons essayer de de surveiller
d'encadrer hein il faut pas qu'il y ait
d'abus et je pense que c'est à vous qui
connaissez et qui suivez ces ces
produits nouveaux de nous dire quels
sont les besoins de de réglementation je
crois que le le Sénat comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président a toujours
répondu présent quand telle ou telle
autorité avait besoin d'un outil
juridique pour encadrer telle ou telle
activité ma question euh c'est euh
pourquoi est-ce que la France est peu
active sur ce marché qu'est-ce qui fait
au fond qu'il y a des pays très actifs
des pays si j'ai bien compris où c'est
interdit bon ça c'est une façon de faire
euh mais à l'intérieur de l'Europe où il
y a pas d'approche commune d'ailleurs si
je comprends bien j'ai compris que la
France était un des pays les moins les
moins actifs qu'est-ce qui fait eu
qu'est-ce qui caractérise cette
situation pourquoi est-ce que c'est
comme ça
euh est-ce que quelqu'un peut nous nous
expliquer euh le marché en quelque sorte
oui j'ai j'ai j'ai bien noté qu'il y a
euh des des des éléments de réponse qui
se prépare je vous demande de bien
vouloir entendre la série de questions
et ensuite vous répondrez les uns et les
autres selon vos vos domaine d'intérêt
de compéten dans l'ensemble des sujets
évoqués la parole est à Monsieur Jacques
Chiron
oui monsieur le monsieur le Président
moi j'ai j'irais sur une question qui
est peut-être plutôt en direction de
Monsieur Cornu sur sur comment se passe
la la rareté du produit au tout début on
créait 50 bitcom toutes les 10 minutes
on a s'est aperçu que ce produit se
développait et aujourd'hui on en crée
plus que 25 donc est-ce que c'est les
programmateurs c'est-à-dire ceux qui
sont à l'origine de la création de cette
monnaie qui sont qui sont les créateurs
de oui ou non bitcom parce qu'on
m'explique que ce sont des mineurs mais
après on voit bien que ça se régule bon
et donc est-ce que cette est-ce qu'il y
a là une spéculation sur la rareté qui
peut commencer à se mettre en place
puisqu'on voit que la monnaie cette
cette pas cette monnaie le cours de
cette de cette création hein monte
excessivement vite est-ce que là on a un
début de spéculation de la part des
décrets des créateurs parce que si on
dit qu'il a il y a très peu d' de
personnes qui sont je dire entre nous
mineur dans ce de ce de ce produit
est-ce que c'est pas eux qui qui créent
la spéculation voilà et donc on
commencerait à voir la réalité du
produit si c'était le cas merci beaucoup
chers collègues la parole est à Philippe
adenau merci monsieur le Président juste
quelques éléments statistiques que
j'aimerais connaître combien y y a-t-il
de mineur
euh puisque l'Allemagne taxe les
plusvalues il faut donc avoir
connaissance
euh
du de ce qui est en cours et de la
variation on sait que la valeur a été
multipliée par
1000 donc ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
savoir la répartition des Bitcoin de
départ pour combien de
mineurs merci beaucoup y y a-t-il
d'autres collègues souhaite prendre la
parole je n'en vois pas monsieur le
rapporteur général vous avez des
questions complémentaires oui euh
brièvement monsieur le Président parce
que nous sommes soucieux d'avoir
quelques éclairage vous avez tous bien
noté que il y avait plus de questions
dans les
interventions de certains de des
intervenants ce matin et et que de
répones réellement donc il y a bien de
grosses interrogations moi je suis en
tout cas curieux de connaître les
réactions de Monsieur Grandval qui qui
est en quelque sorte appeler à la
défense s qu'elle vu les expressions qui
ont pu être émises depuis ce matin en
tout cas moi j'ai à titre personnel le
sentiment que nous sommes au début d'un
processus que l'innovation à la matière
peut être porteuse d'avenir que le souci
de régulation évidemment que nous
relayons ici au Parlement est évident
est évident puisque à partir du moment
on parle de quelque chose de aller égal
ou de de de àécart ou de différents qui
ne rentre pas dans le champ courant de
la régulation il y a bien sûr à
s'interroger moi j'ai trois questions
complémentaires monsieur le Président la
première sur les radars puisqu'il y a
été question de radar tout à l'heure
euh en France il y avait il y a 25 ans
15000 morts sur les routes par an
aujourd'hui c'est euh je sais plus que
3000 3000 on peut penser que les radars
ont contribué
à changer les comportements de des
conducteurs et aujourd'hui il y a des
radars mobiles on crée de l'insécurité
pour chaque conducteur parce que il sait
pas où le radar va se trouver
finalement comment faire pour que votre
comparaison tout à l'heure sur les
radars puisse trouver à à être
concrétisé quant à la surveillance
effective est-ce que il y a d'énormes
efforts à faire pour nous qui avons à
nous occuper aussi des finances
publiques c'est un souci que nous
pouvons avoir ça coûterait très cher
installer des radars partout pour qu'on
puisse mieux surveiller ce C dispositifs
deuxème question sur euh le fait de
savoir s'il y a ou non un pilote dans le
système
Bitcoin existe-t-il un acteur par
exemple un Bitcoin Foundation aux
États-Unis qui pourrait servir de
référents aux autorités au fond d'où
pourrait venir le le regard centralisé
euh je veux pas monsieur le Président
m'engager sur des comparaisons a ce que
vous avez pu dire tout à l'heure sur les
surveillances qui viennent de ces
autorités américaines mais peut-être
c'est une question tout de même sur
laquelle il serait bon d'être éclairé et
puis enfin dernière chose est-ce qu'au
fond on devrait pas rapidement donner à
ces monnaaies virtuelles un statut légal
de manière à mieux pouvoir les réguler
est-ce que c'est pas vers ça qu'il
faudrait tendre rapidement pour une
forme d'intégration euh dans la réalité
régulatrice et également dans les
évolutions de la législation est-ce que
la cette volonté de de mieux intégrer le
plus vite possible ne serait pas la
bonne façon de procéder voilà monsieur
le Président quelques éléments
complémentaires et bien ils sont fort
importants et euh nos interlocuteurs
vont nous aider à nous faire une
conviction
euh peut notamment se demander pourquoi
l'Union européenne qui est si féconde en
réglementation de toute nature sur
toutes sortes de produits et de services
et n'est pas mais peut-être est-elle en
train d'élaborer des règles du jeu
madame damarzit ne nous en a pas
parlé alors donc je vais passer la
parole aux uns et aux autres moi j'ai un
finalement un un souci comment une chose
aussi décentralisée peut-elle engendrer
tous les jours un seul seul cours hein
c'est le fonctionnement du marché c'est
finalement cela qui qui qui m'intéresse
on a tous les jours un cours fixé fixé
comment par qui et qui est le même pour
tous les acteurs de ce marché dans le
monde si j'ai bien compris ou si c'est
pas ça il faut nous l'expliquer estce
que cela veut dire que les différentes
plateformes sont connectées entre elles
est-ce qu'il y a un référent un grand
architecte quelque part non ou ou ou ou
un grand mécanicien enfin je ne sais pas
comment il faut
l'appeler et si l'on arrive à créer un
cours unique tous les jours cela doit
bien vouloir dire qu'il y a un
arbitrage d'une plateforme à une autre
plateforme il y a des écarts de marché
il faut bien les réduire ça suppose
d'intervenir avec des moyens où sont ces
moyens et cetera et cetera alors alors
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
du moins du moins les nôtres et je
voudrais d'abord demander à Monsieur
Grandval bien vouloir réagir donc
ensuite Monsieur le Directeur
Scientifique
ensuite si vous le voulez bien peut-être
tracfine Douine puis Banque de France et
puis naturellement état trésor vers
lequel on se tournera avec révérence
hein alors Monsieur Grandval alors j'ai
essayé de noter à toutes les questions
qui ont été posées je vais tâcher d'y
répondre appelez-moi si j'oublie des des
éléments dans ma réponse euh tout
d'abord vous parliez du du réseau Thor
de silcro
de à propos de de Bitcoin alors petit
point sur Thor Thor est un système
d'anonymisation du trafic sur Internet
qui est une technologie également et
comme toute technologie elle a des
opportunités elle a des risques elle a
des opportunité pour un certain nombre
de d'utilisateurs dont la parole euh
peut-être bannie dans certains pays pour
des journalistes pour ce type de
d'activité et effectivement il peut y
avoir des usages tels que silcad qui
sont condamnables mais Thor est une
technologie complètement déconnectée de
Bitcoin ensuite l'effet SILC est très
intéressant puisque pendant très
longtemps et on continue encore en
France de dire ah Bitcoin l'assimiler
essentiellement à silcod et à la
drogue la le l'investigation du FBI et
le fait que SILC a été fermé a entraîné
une réaction intéressante du marché une
petit un petit frémissement à la baisse
du cours du Bitcoin qui est censé être
le symbole de la de la vitalité de
Bitcoin ce qui n'est pas euh et ensuite
euh un retour à des niveaux de cours
comparable voire supérieur à ce à ce
précédent les études ont montrer qu'il y
avait probablement 1 % des transactions
Bitcoin qui concernent le réseau silcad
dont on disait qu'il était le seul
intérêt de Bitcoin donc force de
constater que non Bitcoin n'est pas
porté par silcad n'est pas porté par des
activités légales il est porté de plus
en plus par des activités de marchands
enfin de commerçants et principalement
aux États-Unis où plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de marchands ont basculé ou en
tout cas se sont convertis à
l'acceptation des paiements par Bitcoin
ce n'est pas le cas en France on en a
pas du tout cette image ici il faut
réaliser ce qui se passe outre
atlantique des dizaines de milliers de
marchands et tous les jours des milliers
de marchands qui basculent sur Bitcoin
donc c'est plus du tout une activité
concentrée sur silcod et sur la drogue
et sur le blanchiment c'est une activité
de paiement électronique qui
effectivement peut trouver euh ass ses
limites euh des activités illégales
contre lesquels on a différents services
ici qui sont tout à fait équipés
normalement pour lutter et nous-mêm les
assistonsou les aidons si besoin euh
dans leur euh dans leur compréhension de
Bitcoin dans leur analyse technique dans
euh dans ce qu'on peut faire dans la
limite de nos compétences également mais
euh j'encourage tous les services de
l'État et tous les services d'ailleurs
commerciaux qui soient bancaires ou
autre à investiguer cette technologie à
monter en compétence parce
qu'effectivement c'est une technologie
complexe qui a été été adopté rapidement
par des gens très malins et très
intelligents à des fins vertueuses ou
moins mais à nos services d'être
également à la hauteur de ces enjeux
technologiques on ne peut pas les
interdire on ne peut pas les arrêter on
ne peut pas les désinventer ils sont là
et il faut conjuguer avec et il faut en
tirer le meilleur en tout cas c'est nous
ce que ce que nous tâchons d'en
faire concernant le nombre de
détenteur de de Bitcoin et le fait que
les les personn étant présente au
démarrage du réseau ont pu accumuler des
quantités de Bitcoin importantes c'est
tout à fait vrai c'est un sujet qui
choque un certain nombre de personnes et
qui pour d'autres est tout à fait normal
considérant que Bitcoin n'est pas une
monnaie mais plutôt comme une part d'un
réseau je considère que les créateurs et
les premiers développeurs et les
premiers acteurs de ce réseau-l ont pris
un risque ont travaillé et ont donc
gagné des Bitcoin de façon plus simple
que les premiers mais finalement si on
rapporte ça à un autre élément de
comparaison on n pas choqué que un Mark
Zuckerberg détienne des dizaines de
milliards de dollars en valeur de sa
société ça choque pas ni la fortune de
Steve Jobs mais finalement sur Bitcoin
et c'est un peu nouveau ça ne choque
personne dans le réseau Bitcoin que les
créateurs qui ont fourni un travail
considérable et qui on apporté une
innovation majeure sur le marché puisse
avoir la rémunération la contrepartie de
leur rapport à l'économie
numérique ils sont ils sont pardon
peut-être on peut on peut difficilement
savoir principe de leur rémunération
c'est une sorte de redevance c'est c'est
c'est un droit de propriété industrielle
c'est tout le principe intellu quo c'est
tout le principe un petit peu complexe
de la création des Bitcoin les bitcoins
sont créés exclusivement en rémunération
du travail réalisé par les processeurs
du réseau donc les bitcoins ne sont
créés que pour ceux qui collabore au
réseau Bitcoin et qui assure sa sécurité
et la transmission des transactions
électroniques donc les premiers
possesseurs de Bitcoin ont été les
premiers opérateurs à véhiculer des
transactions alors effectivement lorsque
le réseau est né et qu'il y avait
quelques dizaines de transaction qui
passaient tous les jours il était
extrêmement simple de gagner 50 Bitcoin
comme on disait à peu près toutes les 10
minutes et puis la complexité du réseau
s'est accru le nombre de transactions
également et donc l'effort à faire pour
gagner ces Bitcoin est devenu de plus en
plus important et aujourd'hui il y a une
véritable compétition entre tous les
processeurs du réseau
qui est vertueuse pu c'est une
compétition qui vise à sécuriser le
réseau et en même temps elle est
rémunérée par la création de
Bitcoin quand on a beaucoup de bitcoins
on en fait quoi comment est-ce qu'on
liquide cette position c'est assez
hybride et vous en faites ce que vous
voulez il y a il y a aucun aucune
instruction qui est donnée à Bitcoin
Bitcoin c'est un logiciel libre donc ou
bien vous les vendez ou bien vous
achetez des biens et services ou bien
vous les conserver ou bien vous vous
faites vous faites ce que vous voulez de
plus en plus on enfin on disait au
départ que c'était surtout un outil
spéculatif j'utiliserai pas le mot
d'épargne hein mais mais presque où les
gens faisaient un placement Bitcoin moi
je considère que euh la valeur de
Bitcoin va augmenter et donc je veux
avoir des bitcoins c'est c'est légitime
la spéculation elle existe à priori sur
l'ensemble des marchés aujourd'hui et
Bitcoin n'y échappe pas comme tout ce
qui a de la valeur euh mais de plus en
plus les usages vont se tourner vers le
paiement c'est ce à quoi on assiste aux
États-Unis où on parle de moins en moins
de Bitcoin comme de la réserve de valeur
on arrête de se focaliser sur le cours
qui augmente de plus ou moins 10 % dans
la journée ou plus d'ailleurs et on se
focalise sur l'intérêt des marchands et
le nombre grandissant de marchands
est-ce qu'il y a des options sur les
bitcoins je crois est-ce qu'on peut
prendre des positions je crois qu'il
existe des opérateurs qui commencent à
travailler sur ce type voilà qui est
fort intéressant alors Monsieur Cornu
est-ce que oui vous terminez s'il vous
plaît pardon oui s'il vous plaît oui oui
oui ou à
traiter une question très intéressante
sur le retard de la
France effec efftivent la France est en
retard je pourrais tirer une certaine
gloire du fait que pemium soit la seule
start-up Bitcoin en France mais au
contraire j'en suis plutôt affligé
et il faut considérer donc les pays qui
sont en avance les pays qui sont en
avance ce sont les États-Unis l'Europe
du Nord de façon générale l'Allemagne en
particulier Israël et puis l'Asie ce
sont des pays qui ont pris des
positions très en avance sur Bitcoin
toutes et leurs régulateurs
leur régulateur ont tous émis le message
que Bitcoin était une innovation
technologique et à ce titre qui était de
leur devoir de l'accompagner pas
forcément de l'encourager parce que
Bitcoin a des risques comme j'indiquis
dans ma note on est on est tout à fait
conscient des risques des que que peut
que peut comporter Bitcoin mais surtout
des opportunités et à ce titre il faut
l'accompagner il faut voir comment ça
fonctionne il faut comprendre tout son
fonctionnement de bout en bout et
ensuite avancer pourquoi pas dans des
termes de régulation parce que on a
quelques idé en la matière qui serait
qui serait important il y a plein de
choses à faire il est important à ce
titre que la régulation si elle a lieu
qu'elle soit lié aux activités bancaires
ou fiscales soit européenne on a
aujourd'hui nous des concurrents en
Europe qui sont normalement tenus
d'appliquer la même réglementation que
nous la même régulation qui ne le font
pas du tout et qui ont des activités qui
ont une
croissance impressionnante par rapport à
la autre parce qu'il fonctionne en
dehors de la réglementation que nous-mêm
avons de notre propre fait décidé de
respecter de façon extrême
quasiment et donc je m'étonne
aujourd'hui qu'en Europe des banques
européennes soumises aux mêmes
réglementation et des États européens
laisse faire des activités aux
frontières de
l'Europe en distorsion complète de la
concurrence à laquelle nous
sommes nous sommes confrontés donc si et
nous l'encourageons une régulation de
ces activités devait avoir lieu il faut
à tout prix qu'elle soit européenne tant
au niveau fiscal qu'au niveau bancaire
sinon c'est assurément la fin de la
France dans notre domaine et l'activité
s'exercera ailleurs aujourd'hui elle a
lieu ailleurs elle a pas lieu en France
il y a très peu de volume en France
la France ne risque rien mais elle
risque tout elle risque tout parce que
tout se passe
ailleurs Internet n'a pas de frontière
et dans ce domain là les G on très bien
compris donc il faut que la France est
une position innovante en la matière
pour pouvoir capter des compétences et
des activités
sur ce domaine du paiement électronique
parce que c'est un domaine qui est
nouveau générateur d'emploi et
d'activité dans le domaine du paiement
électronique du commerce
électronique la création monétaire je
l'ai vaguement vaguement abordé tout à
l'heure sur le nombre de mineurs et sur
la taxation alors la taxation je
laisserai je laisserai ce sujet au aux
personnalités compétentes sur le nombre
de mineurs c'était vous qui posit la
question oui alors je crois qu'on estime
à peu près à à plus de 100000 le nombre
de processeurs sur le réseau euh c'est
moi j'ai j'ai pas les chiffres exacts je
sais pas si mes associés ont une non
c'est à peu près ça donc environ 100000
processeurs sur le réseau qui sont
souvent regroupés dans des ce qu'on
appelle des poules de de minage
c'està-dire que les process se mettre
ensemble pour réussir à capter un peu de
création de de valeur et ce réseau à la
fois se
densifie en en volume mais en valeur
dans le sens en valeur également dans le
sens où la puissance de calcul du réseau
augmente elle-même de jour en jour à ce
titre une
industrie hardware s'est créé autour des
outils de vérification des transactions
Bitcoin il y a une industrie nouvelle
qui est née avec du des systèmes
informatique hardware des composants
informatiques qui ont pour vocation de
traiter et de sécuriser les transactions
du réseau Bitcoin donc c'est vraiment
une nouvelle économie qui est
né sur les pilotes dans le système sur
le statut légal et sur la régulation
pilotes dans le système il existe aux
États-Unis une fondation
Bitcoin qui qui représente en tout cas
qui est une voie d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs de de l'économie Bitcoin nous
avons pour volonté de créer une
association Bitcoin Europe en France ça
serait trop facile il y aurait que nous
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas une
association Bitcoin Europe c'est dans
les c'est dans c'est en préparation pour
par Premium avec avec d'autres d'autres
prestataires
européens quant à la régulation au
statut légal oui le statut légal est
important en tout cas une position telle
que l'a fait l'Allemagne serait serait
serait assez rassurante pour l'ensemble
des acteurs nous on côtoit tous les
jours des entrepreneurs français et
étranger qui nous disent je peux pas le
faire en France c'est quoi le statut en
France je vais le faire en Allemagne
c'est beaucoup plus simple ils ont pris
une position je vais le faire aux
États-Unis c'est simple tous les
régulateurs se sont exprimés je vais le
faire à Singapour c'est simple ils sont
exprimés effectivement je vais peut-être
pas le faire en Chine et au et et en
Thaïlande mais a priori c'est pas non
plus les deux pays que je vise le que je
vise en premier donc oui en Allemagne
aujourd'hui c'est plus simple au
Pays-Bas c'est également plus simple les
régulateurs ont pris des positions assez
claires ouvertes officiell sur Bitcoin
et sur le fait qu'ils allaient
accompagner le le développement donc
c'est important et sur la régulation
nous-même en étant au cœur du
système nous avons des idées et des
propositions à faire en matière de
régulation de nos activités et de ce qui
peut de ce qui peut l'être la régulation
d'un point de vue très positif pour moi
en tant que société je la prends comme
un soutien et une une assurance dans mon
activité aujourd'hui personne ne veut
assurer mon activité
personne volontiers demain je demanderai
à une institution à la Banque de France
de vouloir de lui confier une partie de
la gestion de mes enfin une partie des
dépôts de mes clients en réserve en
disant tenez je vous les donne et c'est
vous qui en assurez la sécurité jeais
tout à fait partant c'est système c'est
des points de régulation qui sont très
importants parce qu' justement on évoque
les difficultés ou les risque liés au
piratage informatique s'il y a en France
des organismes qui sont en mesure et qui
ont les moyens
d'assurer des des données numériques de
façon tout à fait garantie dans la
protection pour la protection des
consommateurs je vous assure que des
acteurs comme nous signons tout de suite
et et applaudiront cette démarche et on
peut imaginer que ce soit moyennant une
honnête redevance pour service rendu ABS
absolument oui oui c'est c'est c'est une
activité dont certains ont
fait enfin on font la commercialisation
en disant nous vous assurons du stockage
de vos Bitcoin chez nous contre telle
telle redevance c'est une activité
extrêmement risquée extrêmement complexe
c'est technique donc il faut il faut
accepter de rentrer dedans et ça
intéressant enfin ce qui est intéressant
les propos de Monsieur Grandval c'est
qu'apparemment il est en attente de
régulation et qui nous dit que la
régulation est un élément de
compétitivité du territoire français
donc c'est c'est c'est c'est un point
qui pour la commission des finances tout
si la France si la France agit avec une
régulation adaptée à Bitcoin elle peut
faire de la France peut devenir un
territoire intéressant pour les
entrepreneurs et pour les activités
liées au paiement électroniqu de demain
mais elle peut aussi rapidement en faire
un territoire que vont déserter les
entrepreneurs et les acteurs de
l'économie du paiement comme vous ctiez
tout à l'heure paypal est un train qui
est passé que tout le monde a regardé
passer les banques les premières souvent
en critiquant et qui all s'installer
ailleurs aujourd'hui les banques ESS de
rattraper le retard mais avec 13 ans de
retard c'est trop
tard